the great ideas of the West rationalism
self-criticism the disinterested surge
for truth the separation of church and
state the rule of law equality before
the law freedom of conscience thought
and expression human rights and liberal
democracy quite an achievement surely
for any civilization Remain the best and
perhaps the only means for all people no
matter what race or Creed to reach their
full potential and live in Freedom that
is why Western values on which is
self-evident economic social political
scientific and cultural success is based
are clearly Superior to any other
devised by
humankind however when these values have
been adopted by other societies similar
benefits have accured to his citizens as
in Japan and South Korea Liberty the
great P the Second Great panel in the
triptic is also an immense human idea it
is embodied in the Magnificent creation
of Human Rights human rights I are I
believe Universal they transcend local
or ethnocentric values and comper equal
dignity and value to all Humanity
regardless of sex ethnicity sexual
preferences and religion I also believe
it is in the west that they are most
respected it is the West that has
liberated women racial minorities
religious minorities gays and lesbians
to an extent unimaginable 60 years ago
it is in the west that their rights are
recognized and defended in the west we
are free to think what we want to read
what we want to practice our religion to
live lives of our own choosing the
notion of Human Rights and Freedom were
I believed there at the dawn of Western
Civilization as ideals at least and
further developed during the
Enlightenment but are only now coming to
frua in the 21st century as a result of
a series of supreme acts of
self-criticism acts of self-criticism
that led to Greater freedom for a
greater number of people it was the West
that took steps to abolish slavery the
calls for the abolition of slavery did
not resonate in Black Africa where rival
African tribes took black prisoners to
be sold in the west by contrast stoning
to death someone for adultery is a clear
violation of the human rights of the
individuals concerned punishments laws
concerning inheritance and the rights of
women prescribed by the Sharia Islamic
law also flagrantly violate the human
rights of individuals under Islamic law
women are not free to marry whom they
wish homosexuals are killed apostates
are to be executed the Quran is not a
rights respecting
document life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness Define succinctly the
attractiveness and superiority of
Western Civilization we are free in the
west to choose we have real choice to
pursue our own desires we are free free
to set the goals and contents of our own
lives the West is made up of individuals
who are free to decide what meaning to
give to their lives in short glory of
the West is that life is an open book
while under Islam life is a closed book
everything has been decided for you God
and the Holy law set limits on the
possible agenda of your life in many
non-western countries especially Islamic
ones we're not free to read what we want
in Saudi Arabia Muslims are not free to
convert to is Christianity and
Christians are not free to practice
their faith all clear violations of the
article 18th of the universal
Declaration of Human Rights this desire
for knowledge no matter where it leads
inherited from the Greeks has led to
another institution that is unequal or
very rarely equal outside the West the
university here the outside world
recognizes the superiority it comes to
the west to learn not only about science
developed in the science is developed in
the West in the the last 500 years in
all Departments of physics biology and
chemistry but also of their own culture
they come to the west to learn of the
Eastern civilization languages
easterners come to Oxford Cambridge or
Harvard and Yale the sborn or heidleberg
to receive their doctorates because they
confer PR Prestige unrivaled by similar
doctorates from the third world
countries a culture that gave the world
the spiritual creations of the classical
music of mozard Beethoven Vagner and
Schubert the paintings of Michelangelo
and Raphael DaVinci and rembrand does
not need lessons from societies whose
idea of spirituality is a heaven people
with female virgins for the use of men
whose idea of Heaven resembles a cosmic
brothel the West has given the world
rather Symphony and a novel even to
paraphrase Alan COA instead of the rigid
inhuman cast system in India we have
unparalleled social mobility in the west
where Western Society is a society of
ever richer more varied more productive
more self-defined and more satisfying
lives it is a society of boundless
private charity it is a society that
broke on behalf of Merit the seemingly
Eternal chains of station by birth the
West has given us liberal Miracle of
individual rights individual
responsibility Merit and human
satisfaction in contrast to the
mind-numbing certainties and rules of
Islam Western Civilization offers what
Russell once called liberating doubt
which leads to the methodological
principles of scientific skepticism
Politics as much as science proceeds by
tentative steps of trial and error open
discussion criticism and self-correction
one could characterize the difference
between the west and the rest as a
difference in epistemological principles
Western institutions such as
universities research institutes and
libraries are at least ideally
independent aies which enshrine these
epistemological norms and where the
pursuit of Truth is conducted in a
spirit of disent inquiry free from
political pressures in other words
behind the success of modern Western
societies with their science and
technology and their open institution
lies a distinct way of looking at the
world interpreting it and the
recognition rectifying of the problems
Bes besetting them problems are lifted
out of the religious sphere and treated
as empirical problem whose Solutions lie
in rational procedur open to rational
inter subjective criticism not in an
appeal to Revelation the whole edifice
of modern science and its methodology is
one of the Great Western man's greatest
gifts to the world but the West did not
only give us just about every scientific
discovery for the last 500 years from
electricity to computers but gave us
thanks to his humanitarian impulses the
Red Cross Doctors Without Frontiers or
borders Human Rights Watch The am anesty
International it is the West that
provides the bulk of the a to Bela darur
Islamic countries are conspicuous by
their absence the West does not need
lectures on the superior virtue of
societies in which women are kept in
subjection endure genital mutilation are
stoned to death for alleged adultery
have acid thrown on their faces are
married off against their will at the
age of nine or whether the human rights
of those considered to belong to lower
costs are denied the West does not need
San monious homilies from societies that
cannot provide clean drinking water for
its citizens that cannot provide sewage
system that cannot educated assistant
leaving 40 to 40 40 to 50% illiterate
that makes no Provisions for the
handicap from societies that have no
sense of the common good civic duty
civic responsibility and Civic
accountability from societies that are
riddled with corruption moreover the
rest of the world recognizes the
superiority of the West it is the West
that millions of refugees from
Theocratic or totalitarian regimes flee
appreciating the West's tolerance and
political Freedom Millions rest their
lives trying to get to the West not to
Saudi Arabia or Iran or Pakistan second
no Western politician would be able to
get away with the kind of racist remarks
made by Mal Maha Malaysian leader no
Western politician could survive in
office there would be calls for his or
her resignation from third world leaders
themselves but also from Western media
and other intellectuals yet we tolerate
mahat anti-semitic diet tribes double
standards yes but also a tacid
acknowledgement that we expect higher
ethical standards from the West there
are no jokes in Islam as K once famously
said the West is able to look at his
foibles and laugh to make fun of his
fundamental principles but there is no
equivalent as yet of Monty Python's Life
of briam can we look forward to the life
of Mo
or half a mo finally when Chinese
students cried and died for democracy in
chanan square they brought with them not
representations of confucious or Buddha
but a model of the Statue of Liberty
thank
[Applause]
you
thank you very much indeed um iban warak
uh for that both for your eloquence and
for your spectacular punctuality you
stopped on the second of your um
allotted 9 minutes and I commend I
commend this practice to the other
speakers Charles over to
you after listening to that I'm very
glad to be a Westerner like George
Nathaniel Ken I feel I am a very
Superior person as a result and I assume
that all of you who look to be mostly
Western feel quite Superior as well and
aren't we Jolly lucky to be Western and
so Superior to those awful nonwestern
Southern and Eastern people not just
Muslims but all of the deprived people
who cannot share our values who are not
fortunate enough to have shared our
values and yet we have had a history of
trying to share our values with them
which goes back a long way not merely to
the Crusades but to the to the to the
did everyone missed what I said before
was brilliant I I'm I because I am a
Westerner I'm very
Superior
now when uh when Ferdinand mellan
arrived at
Madras uh beginning one of the first
demonstrations of the robust assertion
of Western values he ordered the people
of Madras immediately on pain of being
destroyed to expel the Muslims and the
Jews from the city and the elders who
were Hindus Muslims and Jews were rather
puzzled by this because it had never
heard occurred to them to expel the
Muslims and the Jews from any City they
had never done it uh melan gave them a
warning and said when they came back a
year later if they didn't do it the
place would be destroyed and indeed he
came back a year later and they did
destroy the the city and when they went
in and they expelled and killed all of
the Muslims and the Jews they discovered
that there was an ancient Christian sect
there of Syriac Christians who had been
converted to Christianity by St Thomas
the Apostle a much older Church than the
Church of P Portugal and Spain uh they
killed them too they tried them at the
Inquisition for heresy and killed them
as well so when we speak of our values
we don't just assert that our values are
better we Ram them down the throats of
the rest of the world now in this
discussion tonight no one on our side is
going to say that Eastern or Southern or
whatever is a non-western value is
superior we're merely calling upon you
to think carefully what you mean when
you say that you your values or your
race or your culture is superior to all
others not just Islam but to all others
in the world we know what that leads to
and a culture if there is such a thing
as a cohesive Western culture which gave
the 20th century two world wars in which
nearly 100 million people died in which
6 million people were sent to death
camps in one in by the Germans and many
more by the Russians a culture which can
do that um really must be superior if it
can point a finger at others and claim
it claim its moral superiority and in
the aftermath of that the post Colonial
the colonial wars that it fought in the
French fought in Vietnam or killed 2
million people in Algeria or the British
who let 100,000 people die in Kenyan
concentration camps can point their
finger or the Americans who killed 2
million Vietnamese between 1963 and 1972
can point their finger at the Vietnamese
and claim moral superiority or those of
us now I'm a citizen of the United
States by the way I was born in
California much further west than any of
you so I must be even more
Superior the CIA even
today the CIA even today torturing
people at Abu at uh bam Air Base in
Afghanistan in Guantanamo and in a
number of
undisclosed locations around the world
people taken away from their families
and held and tortured for years on end
we are a very very we have very Superior
values and we we have every right to
assert those values in torture chambers
or in the helicopters from which we
threw Viet Kong infrastructure which
meant you were relation possibly of a
Viet Kong member uh from from the
helicopters into the South China Sea yes
we are very very Superior when one
asserts this this notion this ludicrous
notion of racial or cultural or value
superiority one is really denying all of
the crosscultural wealth of our human
Legacy we would we would throw out half
of the Poetry of Gerta who was inspired
by the Persian poet HZ and then we for
we would not that anyone here would read
ikbal but we ikbal who was inspired by
Gerta and wrote poems in honor of Gerta
this is a cross culture what what Gerta
himself called the east west danan where
we could all sit together and exchange
our cultures and exchange our values and
exchange our ideas if if you go in to
that table to sit down to dinner with
another man and or another woman and say
I am Superior you don't have a dialogue
you replace discourse with Discord you
replace jaw jaw with war war you don't
have a chance of enriching even yourself
and if you assert that superiority
you're basically abandoning any hope of
being even an equal so I would call on
you to bear this in mind when you're
conscientiously casting your vote as
good Superior Western people thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you well thank you very much Charles the
contributions are getting shorter and
shorter I'm not sure this is going to
turn into a trend um but we'll see David
aronovich you have 9 minutes if you
choose to take
it uh they were getting shorter um but
I'm sure nobody will mind least of all
uh Charles if I take up his extra minute
that he laid down and so on I no maybe
not I mean first can I say that this is
easily the most distinguished set of
opponents I've ever had in a debate of
this kind and I have debated against
Boris Johnson
so um distinguished writers
distinguished journalists and a
distinguished professor and SP all of
whom I consider to be people who are
people who one can have a dialogue with
a discourse with and not in any sense
enemies um but of course when kind of
considering how this debate was likely
to go I did think that however wonderful
they were the first thing we would
attempt to do would be to throw a kind
of fog of
obscurantism over the course of this
debate because actually we know what
this discussion is really about it's not
about whether or not we think Western
people are superior to Eastern people uh
it's not about race it's not about
literature it is about cultural
relativism that's what this discussion
is essentially about Western values as
we understand
them not just practiced in the west
practice in a large number of places but
usually called Western values are
precisely the ones that iban warak laid
out and we know what they are they are
liberal democracy they are a culture of
Human Rights they are and this is very
important freedom of expression uh they
are freedom of worship and they are
secular government secular government as
a consequence of those previous things
they are freedoms to and they are
freedoms from the fact that the West May
often fall short of its own ideals of
its own values if you like is testified
in the very fact that something like Abu
CRA which was mentioned there by Charles
is regarded by us as a blot on our name
rather than as a matter of good policy
by the government that implemented it as
it would have been by the government of
Saddam Hussein who had Abu grab before
the Americans got
there this is an important distinction
even if it feels less so possibly to the
person who's actually at the end of the
torture I completely accept
that now I agree obviously that Western
values as I've just outlined them can be
practiced in by in many countries their
practice for instance in the liberal
democracy in India in Japan as a
consequence largely the Constitution
imposed upon the Japanese but accepted
by them by the United States after the
end of the second world war it's
practiced in South Korea it's practiced
in many places in Southeast Asia now it
is increasingly practiced around the
world um increasingly because it is very
much more prevalent than it was so I
want to look at one place just for the
moment at which we can see
if you like what a different set of
cultural standards can lead you to and
that is the Islamic Republic of
Iran on the 15th of August 2004 a
16-year-old girl called at sahala was
hanged in a Public Square in the Iranian
city of NAA and her death sentence was
imposed and this is the quote for crimes
against
Chastity uh her father was a drag addict
her mother had died when she was four
she had been arrested by the police for
attending a party and for being alone in
a car with a boy she received her first
senten for crimes against Chast when she
was just 13 which also involved getting
a hundred lashes while in prison she
then she says was raped by a former
revolutionary guard who was
51 when she was tried for this and found
guilty he was found guilty too he was
sentenced to 95 lashes and she was
hanged she was hanged the man who put
the Noose around her neck was the uh
judge who had sentenced her in the first
place Mariam iubi in her early 30s
around about the same time was put to
death at born in teran's aan prison she
was washed wrapped in a white shroud
carried on a stretch to an open space
there she was placed in a hole and Earth
was compacted around her and so on and
she was stoned to death not for the
murder of her husband which she was
found guilty for with somebody else but
for the crime of adultery in May of that
same year a woman who had been waiting
on death row for 8 years was stoned for
corruption on Earth she'd been found
guilty of taking part in a pornographic
film and her execution at that point was
the first stoning for several years uh
and just in case you think the practice
has died out in July this year the
Iranian government confirmed that a man
was executed by stoning in the village
in a small Village near takistan um uh
uh the villagers said the sentence was
carried out by the local judge and
authorities at the same time they
confirmed that 20 other men were to be
given capital punishment for crimes
ranging from adultery to immoral
Behavior to crimes against religion to
sodomy which is almost certainly a
euphemism for homosexuality which is odd
because we now know from president Amed
in his visit to Colombia University that
there are no homosexuals in
[Music]
Iran in the law of the Islamic republ of
Iran the father in a case where people
split up automatically without appeal
gets custody of a boy over two years or
of a girl over seven um in the court of
law two women Witnesses are the equal of
one male and I could go on and so on
this is not some kind of loose notion of
how things should be done some arbitrary
it's not an Abu grabe it's not some kind
of strange uh move away from uh from the
jurisdiction from the jsh pr Prudential
aspects of what Iran does that's their
policy now the reason why you may say
okay this is an extreme example one of
the most extreme example and that's
where I want to take uh you to the agony
what I consider the agony of Professor
tarq Ramadan here who I consider to be a
good man uh a very good man in a debate
in 2003 with the now president Nicholas
sarosi uh T Ramadan was waylaid by sar's
debating style he's not a bad debater
sarosi and he was uh effectively
ambushed and he was asked what he
thought about the practice of stoning
and you replied Tariq that you favored a
moratorium on such practices but you
refused to condemn the law outright
sarosi said I quote a moratorium that is
to say we should for a while hold back
from stoning women and you said no no
wait what does a moratorium mean a
moratorium would mean that we absolutely
end the the application of all of those
penalties in order to have a true debate
and my position is that if we arrive at
a consensus among Muslims it will
necessarily end but you cannot you know
when you're in a community today on
television I can please the French
people who are watching by saying me my
own position but my own position doesn't
count what matters is to bring about an
evolution in Muslim mentalities Mr
sarosi and sarosi you can imagine kind
of getting off on this that's monstrous
to Stone a woman because she's an
adulterate it's necessary to condemn it
and you said t Mr Saros listen to what
I'm saying when I say my own position is
the law is not applicable that's clear
but today I speak to Muslims around the
world and I take part even in the United
States in the Muslim world you should
have a pedagogical posture that makes
people disgust things you can decide all
by yourself to be a progressive in the
communi that's too easy today my
position is that to say we should my
today my position is that is to say we
should stop T what were you saying what
were you saying I think you were saying
that you would lose your audience if you
told them told them that stoning was
wrong that they would somehow be
detached from you if you were to say to
them outright look fol folks stoning
women is wrong it is a value I cannot
uphold it is one that I totally and
absolutely abhor it cannot exist in a
civilized society but you could not say
that to them because that could not be
part of your discourse you then went to
S Ian baruma when uh the author when he
interviewed you on the subject um but
when you are want to be heard in Muslim
countries you said when you're
addressing religious issues you can't
just say it has to stop I think it has
to stop but you have to discuss it
within the religious context there are
texts involved I'm not just talking to
Muslims in Europe but addressing the
implementation of H everywhere in
Indonesia Pakistan the Middle East that
is precisely the point T now are women
to enjoy rights equal to those sorry are
women to enjoy rights equal to those of
men are adults to decide which other
adults they have sex with or is that a
cultural tick and my final point is
this um my father was a member of the
Communist party and he believed for a
while that Stalin was indeed a mighty
man and there were around at that time
many people who would say that the West
was in some way inferior or not Superior
the values of the West American were not
Superior to those properly understood in
the sov if you only just understood the
context you have to learn I think Tariq
your father was very close to H Alana
and so on the Muslim Brotherhood you
have to learn at some point to say no
actually I'm not going along with that
anymore these values of Human Rights
these values of Liberty and so on are
superior and I will support
them